doctors in northern Italy on the front
line of the virus outbreak in just a few
weeks the normally well resourced health
service here has been overloaded with
huge demand for intensive care
ventilators are one of the key pieces of
equipment critical care doctors use they
blow air into the lungs keeping patients
alive the government has called on
manufacturers to step up production of
them for the NHS but intensive care
doctors say that could be easier said
than done we're asking companies here to
produce fence ages in double-quick time
and that will require a lot of work by
the regulatory agency the MHRA week and
they would have to work with the
anesthetic community and the intensive
care community to make sure that what is
produced is to the specification we need
above all they've got to be reliable
foul safe and included as the outbreak
spreads routine operations may also be
postponed freeing up further equipment
we've been raising for some time now the
point about ventilators and we need to
buy up those ventilators we should have
been doing that weeks ago but of course
ventilators need staff to operate them
so we need to understand how stuffing
will be changing in the NHS where
patients are treated could change as
well and the government plans to buy up
private beds to boost capacity spire
healthcare which is headquartered here
in London but runs almost 40 private
hospitals across the country has already
been asked to help but while the
government says the NHS will get
whatever funding it needs others worry
about the number of beds the Health
Service currently has to care for those
with the greatest needs NHS England has
around seven critical care beds for
every 100,000 people by comparison in
the European centre of the outbreak
Italy that figure is 12 while in Germany
it's 29 that disparity is partly because
of differences in admission criteria to
intensive care units in the UK but
doctors say tight budgets haven't helped
it's a result of a decade of
underfunding and now what therefore we
need to do is make some really decisive
decisions on how that limited resource
is used in the best possible way the
government is now putting more money in
to the NHS with an extra five billion
announced last week just to tackle the
virus but with covert 19 cases
increasing by the day time and trained
staff maybe the two commodities the
Health Service needs the most Rob Powell
Sky News in central London